[Music]
in celebration of the New Year the most
common question we've received on the
show for the last few months
is some semblance of this question
John's always talking about this
strategic plan he does with his wife
every year this meeting they have or
this retreat they have what do they talk
about how do they do it like what are
the ins and outs of this thing and then
how do you keep it going throughout the
year right so I want to break down for
you what me and my wife have done why we
do it where it's come from and more
importantly like here's the things we
talk about and here's the way we keep
this thing going throughout the year so
um it started about I don't know 15
years ago I was working at a university
maybe a little bit less than that there
was a the dean of the College of
Business his name was Dr Rick Lidle a
great guy but he came to talk to my team
and one of the things he said that he
did with his family was they did a
strategic plan every year and I was I
was like well of course you're the dean
of a business college that makes sense
sounds lame but cool and then he said
this he said why in the world would I
spend all this time and preparation and
money and Gatherings and all this energy
building a strategic plan for a
business something that is going to go
away
someday and not put that level of time
in energy and intentionality into my
family and the light bulb went off I was
like oh my gosh I'm just expecting my me
to happen I'm expecting my marriage to
happen I'm expecting my money just to
figure itself out I'm just expecting to
I don't know have a Tahoe in three
houses and a whatever and a partridge in
a par Tre I just expecting this crap to
happen and I expect my marriage to be
awesome and the sex to always be amazing
and the kids to raise themselves I just
I mean when he said that I was like yeah
we got to be intentional about this and
then I did nothing I did nothing for a
while I had a couple of ideas maybe we
went to a breakfast on New Year's you
know here and there and then we got to a
place my wife and I where we had to
decide are we going to stay married we
reached a point where we were sitting
across a table a grown-up table and
saying we're going to be adults are we
going to stay married because if we're
going to stay married we can't keep
doing this this has to change this has
to change this has to change and that
started a very I remembered that
conversation with Dr Lidle and so that
started a very intentional strategic
plan so here's what it looks like and
the form people get caught up in the
form the same way they get caught up in
Daily morning routines they get caught
up in what's the exact supplement that's
less
important sometimes um over the last
five to seven years my wife and I have I
think it's more about five or six years
is when we've been doing this really
religiously um once we went out of town
and just spent a weekend together once
we did a progressivist my favorite one
so far was we got a babysitter maybe my
parents were in town but we did an
entire day we started somewhere for
coffee we then went to breakfast we then
went somewhere and went for a walk and
we went to lunch somewhere and then we
spent all afternoon in another coffee
shop and then we had a nice dinner to
kind of wrap up the evening but and then
this year we had to do it on three
separate days some years it's been
awesome just being honest this years it
was not great I wasn't feeling great I
was not super excited about the new year
I came with this picture in my head she
came with that picture in her head and
it was like GH we had to have a fourth
meeting right but here's how we but how
you do it whether you have to break it
up 1 hour increments or I'm going to do
it a couple of Saturdays or I'm going to
do it we're going to go on a retreat
once a year um or twice a year here's
the important thing a carve out some
time very intentional time half a day I
think you can't do it a minimum and and
you got to have four hours to do this
probably more that means somebody's got
to get child care somebody's got to ask
their mom and dad to come up and visit
or maybe you're on the holidays and
you're staying at your in-law's house we
did that one year where we went away and
we left the kids while we were on
vacation we went away and did it set
aside some intentional time decide on a
budget for the
day we're GNA we're going to spend 500
bucks today we're going to spend $100
today we don't have any money at all so
we're going to just do coffee and water
and then we're going to eat at
McDonald's to celebrate I don't care
what it is um pick the time in the place
and then here's this is important you
got to do your homework separately and
if you're not willing to do separate
homework you're not willing to have this
meeting and you probably have bigger
issues in your marriage and homework
does not mean you have to do a whole
year okay here's what the homework is
here's some questions and this is from a
list that my wife and I actually use
ourselves how do you feel about last
year what are some things from last year
you're really proud of what are some
challenges you
faced and here's what you find you're
going to find that that um y'all didn't
know the other person was facing this
challenge or maybe you absolutely did
know but you're going to find some
things out um what are you most looking
forward to next year who are you
becoming what are four or five ways I
could love you
better each one of these can be answered
in five minutes most of the time it goes
all it talks and then it opens up this
can of worms and whatever whatever
reflect on the past year what do we need
to grieve this one was really important
for us this year we had some Big Dreams
and the dreams didn't die they just
changed and I realized I'm still holding
on to this thing but everything's
different now what do we need to
grieve what Milestones do we need to
celebrate stop and celebrate how did we
handle challenges as a team is there
anything we like to change next year and
then we're going to get into the hard
conversations we're going to talk about
sex and intimacy we're going to talk
about our health we're going to talk
about parenting how are you feeling have
you got a blood test I've gained 30
pounds you look like you don't feel good
I feel separate from you whatever that
happens to be parenting how are our kids
doing and how are we both working
together to support our kids money is a
big one money's a big one I'm going to
link to this um in the show notes a lot
of this can be funneled through money um
every dollar is the best budgeting app
on planet Earth and it forces couples to
sit at a table and decide what is
important to us and how do we want to
spend our money um I'm going to put a
link to is I think it's free month or
three months or something like that of
the premium version of it um but I'll
put a link to in the show notes it's
awesome it's the one I use with my
family uh with my wife um schedule and
commitments my wife and I go through a
calendar then we talk about work I don't
have a book coming out this year but I
did last year so last year we a lot of
our conversation was what's life going
to be like when you're on touring the
country this year it's going to be a
little bit different the conversations
but we put those things on the calendar
and we put big plans for trips or not
trips or holidays or whatever that thing
is then we get very granular and decide
action
items who's going to actually hit the
button to to pay this
bill who is going to call for the sitter
we okay we're gonna have date night
every two weeks who's going to call the
sitter because one of you is just going
to expect the other one to do it let's
just sit down and go through all of
those
things and then what my wife and I do
every every week CU we get together um
we used to do it on Sunday nights this
year we're going to start doing it more
on Saturday mornings and I give my kids
screen time once a week because I'm in
the enderal until they'll Sprint
upstairs and play video game or watch
cartoons whatever my wife I will spend
several hours working through the week
and then we go for a really really long
long long walk a long Rock um and we
make that a plan we do that every
Saturday just kind of becomes the way
things are sometimes the Saturday
conversations aren't pretty they're more
of us bickering and fighting and I can't
believe this and I don't feel like this
and whatever sometimes there's so
energetic and awesome it's just the EB
and flow it's a roller coaster right I'm
not getting off so it's just part of the
ride and then here's the important
thing over the years you'll tailor this
to yourself I'm actually thinking about
coming up with a leatherbound journal
for couples that you would take on your
retreat at the beginning of the year and
then you would fill it in every week for
your weekly meetings if you're
interested in that shoot me a DM on
Instagram or email the show um john.com
askk um let me know if you're into that
because it would be a I want it to be
something that both that a dude's not
going to feel weird carrying around but
that would be good for everybody and
here's my dream my dream is you would
have 10 of these or 15 of these and or
25 of these journals and your kids will
get to watch The Arc of their parents
what they worked through what they
thought through what their budget was 25
years ago versus what what it is now how
you handled X or Y or Z or whatever um
but I'd love to have a really nice
strong um leatherbound like here's our
strategic plan this is going to get us
through the year and here's the final
thing know that life will change
somebody will get cancer some kids gonna
get sick some kids going to have to
leave school something's someone's going
to have to fly to home to Texas because
Something's Happened to Dad whatever the
thing is hold it
Loosely plan really well and then hold
it Loosely cuz once the once the bullets
start flying then things kind of go out
the window that's the point of the plan
point a of the plan oh I'll just say
what Patrick lenon
says the importance of is the plan part
of the Strategic plan it's a byproduct
it's a byproduct of actually getting
together and talking and listening and
going back and forth and getting on the
same page the plan is cool but the
plan's going to change what's not going
to change is that you and your partner
get
together and say come what may I'm going
to be right here and you can count on me
and I'm going to count on you and we
have some agreement about where we're
headed and if life throws us a curveball
we're going to sit down and talk about
it and then we're going to go from there
but that's what we do every year um we
do have a summer we get together for
half a day just to kind of check in see
how things are going how are you doing
you still like me that kind of stuff um
but the beginning of the year that
strategic planning season is really
really important and what's now fun is
looking back five years ago and saying I
want to have this much money I want to
have a house I want our kids to be this
healthy and safe and to look and see man
we've accomplished a lot of that stuff
it's pretty awesome to watch The Journey
so use that for how you will I'm going
to put a link to this PDF that my wife
and I use in the show notes here and you
can check it
out